il se sent chez lui à la villa négoaque
voici ma chambre que je demeure dedans
que je suis très contente d'y être sa
chambre regorge de ses trésors de vie
les photos de sa famille surtout dont il
nous parle fièrement
il y a pas de raison la raison n'est pas
très claire le gouvernement se contente
de dire qu'une enquête a permis de
découvrir des problèmes liés au
fonctionnement des deux établissements
la villa négoac et le foyer
Saint-Bernard situé quelques kilomètres
plus loin tout le monde pleurait madame
[Musique]
secouer lui aussi par tout ce qui se
passe il ne sait pas par où commencer
ses recherches de nouveaux logements
même si la reçu une liste hier avec la
lettre du gouvernement
monsieur comment on aime pas les
déménagements
à l'entrée de la Villa negoak les
employés sont réunis encore stupéfaites
de la tournure des événements elle
perdront leur emploi certes mais
s'inquiète surtout pour l'avenir de leur
résidence si difficile pour eux
ça se fait pas sortir du monde en plein
milieu hiver
madame Isabelle a 98 ans sa nièce vient
la voir quelquefois par semaine ce ne
sera plus possible si elle déménage il
n'y a aucun foyer à moins d'une
trentaine de minutes de route moi je
pense qu'elle pourra passer à travers
parce qu'elle n'aime pas les changements
du tout du tout puis à la 98 ans
il y avait des problèmes mais pourquoi
que les problèmes ont jamais été réglés
avant
avant d'être rendu là aujourd'hui il y a
quelqu'un pour moi personnellement
tout ça est nébuleux pour Léo entre deux
larmes il dit espérer trouver une place
ailleurs
on cherche pour la langue
[Musique]
Jésus mais il y a de madame qui m'envoie
des appartements chez lol pour deux
que tout le monde va aller on est 26 son
plus grand souhait et que ce ne soit
qu'un mauvais rêve et que tout reviendra
à la normale sous peu ici Michel Bridou
Radio-Canada Nigo